in the Conference Finals he has been
just superb for the Nuggets this year
Davis misses jokes the rebounds
the Elkins nice feed to Gordon and the
Finish
I mean that's the perfect example of the
different score goes inside blocked by
Davis the leading shot Blocker in the
playoffs
Rooter runs to the corner hesitated a
moment that Nails the three brings it on
the pack turns fires away again
the Elkins comes in for the rebound
and new 14 on the clock Caldwell polt
reverse Mystic Joker John the second
catch is good he's relentless on the
board
Anthony Davis nice move to get away from
Martin he thought he got hit as well so
he'll get Joe written five rebounds got
a few of them on that last possession
Murray for three a hot start from the
Nuggets I'll tell you the rest of it was
disaster the way to Lakers are Sprint
back in transition right now poor job
four pass on a turnover in all members
so far Murray Joker's right there for
the following thing three for their
first 11 from the field
[Applause]
all right
what a great not a good a great shooter
he is well they run Flex action and they
run it for a catch and shoot for their
Center
uh at the Gordon open three
you'll catch another rebound block by
Davis a terrific defensive play from
Anthony Davis bringing it up the floor
throws it ahead Porter fakes side step
three-pointer in and out the Elkins
another rebound and the putback
he's got 10 rebounds already just
unbelievable great hands great touch
that's not just hachimura's
responsibility using that size and
strength for the putback
Davis goes right out of blocked by okay
shot blocking
the Guardians not as much of a factor
against Golden State and they don't need
him here in the conference final
he ought to spin finds Caldwell pulp
hunting
that is as good of 10 minutes as you can
possibly play hitting Caldwell Pope one
more time for an easy layer
are we trying to find some room
jokic blocked by Davis that's his third
rejection
great defense again from Davis I mean
that's he caught it with two feet in the
paint and just Exquisite timing by
Anthony Davis
[Applause]
that's just beautiful so you're able to
catch your second win but it's not it's
not a fluke
which goes inside lays it up and in now
when you played here did you notice a
difference in when the opponent came in
why are you laughing it's not just
fluffy
Shooters pass to flex but it goes to
Davis Davis Turn shoots and scores and
Davis is trying to get some Rhythm cuts
it to 10 Again hands off quarter quarter
same spot as before and lets it Fly this
is that Court he took the rebound gives
him another look yoka trip three
pointers that's good
goes a quarter flips it out
all well closes on reads off the dribble
Canyon of the Fall James the rebound all
in a pass barely touched it and Davis
gets a dump
for the dump
and then previously this is a big time
move spin drop step
finish at The Rim over the contest
[Applause]
Davis inside the athleticism from
Anthony Davis
[Applause]
Murray connect
three-pointer Jamal Murray gifted
shooter
as Davis lines that one up
[Applause]
but he Davis now with 16 points here in
the first half
foreign
[Applause]
they didn't want him on Davis to
possibly pick up that third foul
Murray finds some space jumper again
lethal from mid-range Jamal Murray the
Nuggets 53 Lisa and it's a 20-point lead
and this is the largest of the game
James tries to answer Reeves the rebound
back to James nice pass Davis not
expecting it but catches and finishes
what do you mean you only walked it why
wouldn't you play it it was a shortcut
to Wegmans the oak it gets inside and
scores had to work hard for that one
quarter ten points and eight rebounds
has played well
Joker strives down a lane and Banks it
in what a touch she has
[Applause]
said he wants to force all that action
not allowing back cuts to force it to
the to the ball
Intruder back to Davis Davis with a
great touch on a floater
six minutes to go in the third quarter
his sixth of these playoffs
Caldwell pumped in Rhythm knocks down
another back up to 20 timeout Lakers
Monte Morris Will Barton who's in that
starting lineup and Jeff Green
New York it's a three-pointer it's good
Nicole 93-72
Davis answers back how about Davis he's
got 26 points he's 11 of 18 from the
field if you will not run back and get
matched up there's no chance
Caldwell pulse punch it in
contempius Caldwell Holt now with 13
points Davis and brown on him
draws the foul shot is good and one
Anthony Davis got aggressive move and a
chance for a three-point plus Murray
jokic
Texas time spins
looking falling away it's good
foreign
Lakers with 38 points here in the third
quarter they've cut it to 11.
the jokic just gets it off in time it's
up
of course it goes in jokic from downtown
Anthony Davis just stares at him 12
assists even the desperation shots go in
[Music]
extraordinary
[Applause]
[Music]
after the Lakers climb back the jokic
able to connect
off Jeff Green James I slipped past
Davis inside the hachimore beautiful
pass from Davis
[Applause]
tries a three-pointer that's good
Anthony Davis from downtown
right back to Jokers shot clock at six
Caldwell Paul another three
I did not see that one Jeff that's why I
needed a partner like you out there to
see them
Davis throws it up puts it in you don't
know how many times I've heard an
official say I didn't see that